décembre 2010 rue saint-denis à paris
il est 3 heures du matin à 7h le
trottoir est presque désert j'ai salué
les femmes qui affronte le froid dans la
tente d'un client à la semaine prochaine
père jacques monte elle répondu mais je
ne serai pas au rendez vous demain après
avoir célébré la messe pour la dernière
fois je quitterai mon couvent et l'état
de prêtres je n'irai donc plus rendre
visite aux femmes qui se prostituent rue
saint-denis où j'étais leur curé durant
17 ans pour autant je continuerai à
travailler au cnes à l' agence spatiale
française où je suis chargée de
réfléchir aux questions éthiques que
posent les activités spatiales
c'est une ag volontairement tourné une
page une page sur laquelle s'écrivait
mon existence d'homme le jour à l'
agence spatiale française
certaines nuits sur les trottoirs de
paris connu de tous comme prêtre une vie
qui loin de m'avoir écartelé m'a au
contraire ramener à une seule question
comment agir
quel choix opérés quelle décision
prendre pour être pour demeurer pour
devenir humain rien a priori ne me
destinais à passer toutes ses nuits dans
un quartier de prostitution j'étais
étudiant en théologie prêtre de fraîche
date
lorsque les bénévoles d'une association
catholique des deux personnes
prostituées monte invités à les
rejoindre
j'ai accepté je n'avais pas d'objectif
de conversion pas de discours
moralisateur prêt à l'emploi
pas même de but caritatif
je voulais simplement rendre service à
cette association et découvrir un monde
que je ne connaissais absolument pas
j'étais alors ce qu'on appelle un cave
vierge à bien des égards
et pourtant si quelque chose ou plutôt
quelqu'un m'avait discrètement à tirer
sur le trottoir marie-madeleine une
femme de mauvaise vie
une pécheresse comme l'on disait alors
qu'ils avaient suivi ce jésus de
palestine qui était et qui reste
toujours mon maître je me demandais
comment jésus avait agi à son égard
quel regard ils avaient porté sur cette
femme étrange et attachante qui occupe
une place si importante dans la
tradition catholique
marie madeleine est pour quelque chose
dans ma rencontre des prostituées de la
rue saint denis
un soir l'une d'entre elles m'a invité à
prendre un café père jacques matte elle
demandé pouvez vous bénir mon studio
celui où elle accueillait ses clients
bien évidemment
j'ai réfléchi et je lui répondu vous
savez que du point de vue de la morale
je n'approuve pas la prostitution je ne
peux donc pas bénir votre studio mais je
vous propose que nous nous y rendions
pour prier il prie pour vous y prier
pour vos clients
puis je vous bénis ray dieu ne refuse
jamais sa bénédiction à ses enfants
elle accepta c'était une des premières
fois que j'entrais dans un studio de la
rue saint denis
je crois que ce soir là nous avons agi
d'une manière juste
d'ailleurs plus personne ne m'a ensuite
demandé de bénir un studio parfois des
médailles ce que je faisais après avoir
béni celui ou celle qui m'avait
sollicité mon attitude à l'égard de la
prostitution est elle trop tolérante
mais c'est précisément à davantage de
tolérance que j'invite à l'égard de ceux
et de celles qui vivent et qui agissent
dans ce milieu si du moins par tolérance
j'entends l'attitude qui consiste à
respecter la personne humaine voire
aller mais avec lucidité et en vérité or
nous manquons nous pas d'une telle
tolérance
lorsque nous pensons pouvoir régler la
question de la prostitution en élaborant
et en appliquant une nouvelle loi comme
pour nous donner bonne conscience
oublions nous ces jeunes étudiantes
ces mères de famille qui se prostituent
pour parvenir à finir le mois
oublions
ces femmes venues de l'étranger soumise
à des réseaux mafieux d'une rare
violence
oublions nous ces hommes en errance
sexuelle en solitude psychologique dont
des prostituées m'ont parfois parlé avec
une étonnante tendresse nous contenter
de coller une contravention de pénaliser
les uns les autres c'est refuser de nous
laisser interroger parce que leur
pratique 10 de nos sociétés
ce qu'elles disent du regard que nous
hommes et femmes portons les uns sur les
autres nous contenter de pénaliser ce
n'est pas j'en suis convaincu agir d'une
manière juste respectueuse et lucide
vis-à-vis de cette situation je sais
qu'il est plus facile d'appliquer une
loi un règlement je rencontre cette
difficulté dans la mission qui est la
mienne au cnes l'agencé spatiale
française
lorsque j'ai été nommé expert éthiques
certains de mes collègues ont pris peur
il va nous empêcher de travailler
nous ne leur ai je répondu si vous êtes
des ingénieurs des chercheurs sérieux
vous pratiquez déjà à l'éthique
peut-être sans le savoir vous vous
interrogez sur le pourquoi sur les
raisons des missions que vous démarrez
vous chercher les moyens les meilleurs
les plus justes les plus adaptées pour
réaliser vos objectifs et vous êtes
soucieux des conséquences de vos
activités
moi je suis là pour vous accompagner
dans ces indispensables interrogations
et les partager avec nos concitoyens
ainsi
l'usagé croissant des images satellites
en particulier par le biais d'internet
nous a conduit à nous interroger sur
l'impact social de ces techniques
spatiales d'observation de surveillance
et de communication grâce à elle chacun
d'entre nous peut désormais accéder à
une quantité et une qualité
d'information absolument inédite
menace-t-elle nos vies privées
sommes nous prêts à les mettre à la
disposition et au service de chacun
devons nous laisser dominer la loi du
marché
ces questions méritent d'être posées et
débattue après les succès des missions
apollo durant les années 1960
l'exploration de l'espace se poursuit
désormais grâce à des sondes qui
visitent une à une les planètes du
système solaire et même certains corps
célestes souvenez vous fin 2014 filet se
pose sur la comète churyumov gerasimenko
car les comètes ont pu jouer un rôle
important dans l'émergence de la vie sur
terre en lui apportant de l'eau et des
molécules organiques complexes afin de
poursuivre la recherche d'une fille
extra terrestres des humains se poseront
sur la planète mars dans un avenir
difficile à connaître à quel point est
il raisonnable d'investir des moyens
techniques financiers et humains aussi
important pour entreprendre ces missions
alors que notre humanité rencontre 30 en
difficulté sur terre dans quelle mesure
l'exploration de l'espace nous est elle
nécessaire quelle attitude adopteront
nous si effectivement nous découvrons
une vie extraterrestre
loin de relever de la seule imagination
ces questions nous conduisent aux
frontières de nos savoirs et nous amène
à penser différemment à mes collègues
spécialistes de la gestion des débris
dans l'espace m'a conforté dans ma
mission au cours d'une conférence à
laquelle j'assistais jacques at il tenu
à dire m'a rendu un grand service
le jour où il a expliqué que produire
des déchets ce que nous faisons chaque
fois que nous lançons une fusée ou un
satellite produire des déchets c'est
normal la moindre des bactéries pour
vivre fait de même ce qui est essentiel
c'est d'apprendre à gérer ses déchets
ces débris spatiaux ainsi at il conclu
cette réflexion m'a déculpabiliser et en
même temps davantage responsabilisés
c'est cela les tic accepté de prendre la
mesure des actes que nous posons que
nous posons reconnaître l'histoire au
sein de laquelle ils s'insèrent la
manière dont ils contribuer à
l'accomplissement de la personne humaine
ou à sa destruction
enfin prendre conscience des
responsabilités qui en découlent pour
nous ensuite pourra venir le temps de la
décision du jugement
voire du code de bonne conduite de la
loi adopté une posture éthique c'est
accepter c'est choisir de placer l'être
humain c'est à dire chacun d'entre nous
dans sa singularité dans son désir de
bonheur et de réussite avant le
règlement
je me souviens d'un entretien avec un
religieux de mon courant malgré mon
jeune âge je venais d'être élu supérieur
de ma communauté
ce frère avait défendu durant les années
1970 des idées très progressiste et il
menait désormais une vie à part du
couvent
j'ai rapidement compris qu'il voulait me
rencontrer pour justifier ce choix de
vie
j'ai décidé de quitter cette position de
représentants de l'autorité
j'ai donc interrompu son plaidoyer pour
lui poser une seule question et tu
heureux
il m'a regardé surpris et satisfait que
je décide ainsi d'aller d'emblée à
l'essentiel quitte ensuite à nous
interroger ensemble cette fois sur le
bien fondé sur la justesse de tel ou tel
aspect son existence qui pouvaient lui
poser des difficultés ou questionner son
entourage je garde une grande
reconnaissance à l'égard de cet homme
pour m'avoir ainsi appris à quitter un
rôle d'autorité et moralisatrice pour
une posture éthique
si mes propos vous paraissent trop
idyllique
rassurez vous mes nuits sur le trottoir
et dans d'autres lieux qui lui sont
associés ont souvent ramené mes pieds
sur terre et puis j'ai dû moi-même un
jour prendre une délicate décision
ma rencontre avec celle qui est
aujourd'hui un compagne ne relève pas du
coup de foudre
le ciel ne m'a pas offert cette mise en
scène mon amour pour elle notre amour a
grandi peu à peu il est devenu pour nous
une évidence
jusqu'au jour où je me suis retrouvé
dans un confortable fauteuil en cuir au
milieu de la bibliothèque d'un couvent
américain c'était durant l'été 2010 je
savais que la double vie dans laquelle
je m'installais la semaine religieux est
chargé des questions d'éthique à
l'agencé spatiale française le dimanche
en couple je savais que cette double vie
n'était pas juste
elle n'était pas juste pour celles que
j'ai mais elle n'était pas juste pour
ceux et celles qui m'accueillait qui
m'attendait comme prêtre
enfin n'était pas juste pour moi même
jamais jusque là je n'avais dû affronter
ces moments d'angoissé qui désormais
troublé mais nuit dans mon fauteuil
j'ai eu la conviction que je devais
prendre une décision et si je quittais
la prêtrise me suis-je dit peut-être
pour la première fois je m'étais en
question 25 ans de ma vie de l'éthique à
l'état brut
appliqué à moi même je décidé de rompre
mes voeux je ne crois pas que nous
destin soit inscrit dans le ciel en être
étoilé
je crois plutôt que c'est nous qui
écrivons nos destins dans le ciel comme
le font mes amis astronautes et mes amis
aviateurs sans pourtant et pour
longtemps encore échapper à la pesanteur
de notre condition humaine
agissons nous toujours avec justesse
bien évidemment non mais si nous
cherchons un moyen d'évaluer la qualité
de nos décisions et de nos actes je veux
simplement dire une chose
cette nuit de décembre 2010 lorsque j'ai
quitté mes amis de la rue saint-denis et
quelques heures plus tard mon couvent je
n'ai pas eu un instant d'hésitation à
mes interrogations à mes angoisses avait
déjà succédé un sentiment de paix comme
je n'en n'avait jusque là jamais connu
aujourd'hui je poursuis ma mission au
cnes mes collègues et moi même nous
interrogeons par exemple sur l' usage
des satellites en matière de santé
numérique ou sur les programmes futurs
d'exploitation minière des astéroïdes
pour autant je ne dirais pas que j'ai
fait de l'éthique mon métier avec les
hommes et les femmes de la rue saint
denis
avec les religieux de mon couvent avec
mes collègues du cnes j'ai seulement eu
l'occasion la chance le goût de nous
poser des questions parfois inédites
sans jamais être assurés de trouver une
réponse oui c'est cela les tic accepté
de prendre le temps et les moyens de
nous interroger sur ce que nous sommes
et sur ce que nous faisons sur ce que
nous voulons et sur ce que nous
craignons accepté de nous interroger
ainsi sans jamais être certain de
trouver une réponse qui s'impose
accepter enfin de prendre une daisy et
d'agir merci